Social Security must balance its books.
Because Social Security is funded by a trust fund
that was insisted upon,
by FDR and the rest of Congress.
The surpluses from Social Security will be used each year
to cover other expenses of the federal government.
All the money got spent and then some
leaving no money to invest in assets to create a trust fund.
All of finance is a claim,
a paper claim, on assets.
What is real is whether or not you'll be paid back
and the US government is good for its money.
And we're lucky
to have that much money in our trust fund.
Every lie we tell ourselves
incurs a debt to the truth.
Sooner or later that debt must be paid.
Tonight's resolution reads
given Social Security's
nearly three trillion dollar
trust fund
the system cannot add to the federal deficit.
Arguing for the affirmative, Professor Teresa Ghilarducci.
Teresa, Teresa. Please come to the stage.
Arguing for the negative will be me,
so I hereby recuse myself from moderating
and hand that job over to Reason Editor-at-Large Nick Gillespie,
Nick please come to the stage.
Thank you very much Gene.
I'm gonna keep my eye on you.
I told Teresa earlier, you know that
you're a home court advantage
but I'm with her as the ref,
that the the ref is against you Gene.
So keep it clean.
We want to see your hands where we can see them.
Okay.
So many of you have been here before. This is an Oxford style debate.
Teresa is gonna go first.
Make sure if—is the voting closed?
Okay, so if you haven't voted,
go to Sohovote.com and vote.
What?
We're gonna close it in like 30 seconds here.
Teresa is going to talk for up to 15 minutes
and make her argument in favor of the proposition.
Gene, we'll give 15 minutes.
They'll have 5 minutes of rebuttal to each other,
and then we're gonna open it up to you guys,
30 minutes of Q&A.
Let's have an interesting,
wide-ranging conversation about Social Security deficits
and what we're gonna do to screw over Dave Smith's kid.
All right, so Teresa, please.
Hey, that's not fair.
I'm not the first up Nick and Dave were the first up in their negative views of Social Security
So I am here to persuade you to change your mind. So
To vote for my argument. You'll be voting. Yes. You'll be voting YES for the affirmative
Which is given Social Security's nearly three thousand three trillion
Trust fund the system cannot add to the federal deficit that's affirmative
I'm going to argue it and you will vote for me at the end of this time despite
the eight wrong things Dave said about Social Security
Another eight in the last 30 seconds, but he said seventeen funny things, so he's forgiven
Social Security can't by law
And by precedent and by culture add to the federal deficit and the federal debt
medic can food stamps
can the unemployment insurance fund can tax cuts can a
War with Iran can but not Social Security by law Social Security must balance its books
Because Social Security is funded by a trust fund that was insisted upon
by FDR and the rest of Congress Republicans and Democrats
now a trust fund funding mechanism means that
the fund collects the revenues and then pays out the benefits, but the
calculations are based on what's called an actuarial funded standard, which means that
current and projected revenue is
Set to equal and it's always titrated over time
to equal
projected
liabilities
the United States stands alone from all other
developed and developing countries
By using a very conservative
Actuarial standard it projects out 75 years rather than the standard 35 years
So at the very beginning it was meant to pay for itself and it was meant to do so in a very conservative way
Social Security liabilities, of course are the promised benefits
the Internet's determined by the number of beneficiaries that's key because that goes back to David's baby and
the amount of benefit generosity
The administrative costs are also a liability, but they're tiny
It's a much more efficient system than the 401 K and the IRA you're suckered into having but that's another issue
now Social Security
Actuaries know what the benefit generosity is and they could also count they count the babies that are born and they project that within
62 to 70 years
Many of those babies most of them will be collecting Social Security benefits
So the calculation of the projected liabilities are easy
the fact that there is a baby boomer does not faze the actuaries even though everybody now is throwing up their hands and saying
There's a generational tsunami. It is not an issue
in the Social Security trust fund
the benefit generosity the fact that people are living longer is
Also not an issue in terms of the Social Security funding all those were predicted and part of this
75 year projected actuarial
standard funding it was brilliant and
Responsible to
Pay for every promised benefit
we had a trust fund that was quite small up into 80 from
1985 and then thinking ahead again the Social Security actuaries projecting ahead said we're going to have a lot of
Babies, we collect your Social Security right about now and so will advance fund for their retirement
And so taxes were raised
much more to cut then to cover current benefits and that is why the
Trust fund is now almost three trillion dollars and why now that started about a year and a half ago
We are redeeming those bonds to pay for
retirements
now I would think that all conservatives and libertarians would like this kind of
small-bore government program
Would want all of government to be run like Social Security you anticipate the liabilities
They're pretty small Social Security benefits are among the small of any
Development any developed country and that you would want rules to make sure that it pays for itself
advance funding Social Security like we did in
1984 is like we are supposed to do to plan for our own retirement while we work we save
We invest in the private market and then when time comes we redeem our pension or 401ks or IRA
with the assets that we have when we reach retirement age and for most of us a
Big part of our assets are government bonds the same assets that are in the Social Security trust fund
Now currently as we said truck the Social Security trust fund holds 2.8 trillion dollars
In government bonds. Thanks to this
1984 plan that means that even though half of us don't have any pension or a
401 K or an arrey or any kind of retirement plan
Can I repeat that half of us don't have anything but social security we all own
Some government bonds. We're all investors through the Social Security system
Now through the combination of tax revenues and earnings and principles from the trust fund
Social Security is estimated to be solvent into 2035. So remember that number 2035
after that
If the system doesn't get any more revenues then or doesn't get any revenues now starting right now
The results will be horrible
Social Security will only pay
77% of promised benefits
That's you me our relatives now
These will be tragic consequences
But it's stark proof that the Social Security system can't add to the deficit or debt because it pays for itself now
Let me go a little bit deeper
when we through Social Security invest in government bonds
the government creates an intergovernmental debt in
Contrast when China buys our governmental bonds, it creates an external debt
Which China redeems its bonds US taxpayers indeed pay them back with interest coming from general revenues when the Social Security?
Administration redeems its bonds another part of the government transfers assets to another part of government
It's like the $20 bill the $20 you borrowed from your spouse this morning
The nation as your household has the same wealth and created no debt as it did before
so because Americans buy government debt
And there's a transfer there is no change in the debt and the deficit so why do smart people?
Think wrong things like Social Security adds to the budget deficit and debt
It's because of confused accounting and because of politics so Dean are sympathetic
If you think Social Security can add to the deficit in debt, you've been misled
First the accounting confusions the deficit Control Act of 1984 required that this Congressional Budget Office
That's the office the CBO that produces outlooks for Congress
It required it to an accounting convention that contradicts
Established social security law on practice instead of the CBO basing their projections on current law
Which show that Social Security can create no deficit or debt the law passed under President Reagan?
Requires the CBO and what it ever does when it reports to Congress
to assume that Social Security can draw from the general budget then that will happen in 2035 and
Not cut benefits, but that isn't what the law says and that's not what will happen. So in its debt projections
It adds trillions and trillions and trillions of dollars to the debt, but that's just an accounting mistake
the law bars Social Security from taking from general
Revenues now second is the accounting trick of the unified budget which Jean might argue makes it look like Social Security
Creates a deficit as I said Social Security is now redeeming Treasury bonds held in the trust fund
So we see a transfer from one part of the government to another
If Social Security is unified in the budget its included in the whole budget
then
Though it only can spend what it takes in it looks as if the system is drawing from general revenues
But only looking at the Social Security now here in Soho
in
It looks like it's causing the deficit but because it's cashing in its bonds, but it ignores all the other time
It was in surplus and made the deficit look a lot smaller
Arguing that Social Security is causing a deficit is just as wrong as saying that a retiree who lives on five thousand dollars a month
Gets $100 $100 from a part-time job and gets four thousand nine hundred dollars from redeeming
their treasury bonds in their retirement fund is a retiree and deficit because they earn only
$100 but spend five thousand
But that household is not living beyond its means it's not creating a deficit or debt in modern societies
We save to pay for expenses later
Now a related mistake is arguing that since Social Security can be viewed in the unified budget
It masks the true side size of the federal deficit, but everyone literally everyone making decisions about spending
Is fully aware of the legal and economic relationship of Social Security in the rest of the budget the unified budget might create
might include Social Security trust fund on the ledger
but the Social Security deficits are not added to the debt and therefore Social Security trust funds don't
Make the deficit either smaller or larger now here are the politics when I told people I was participating in this debate
One was a physics student. They said really everyone knows Social Security can't contribute to the deficit
Benefits are going to be cut if we don't raise revenue. So why are we having this debate?
is it just are we having a debate this nice Monday summer afternoon because of the counting I
Suspect we're having this debate for deeply political reasons
There
It's very clear that
There are many people that want Social Security to look bad and bad is creating deficits in debt
In an october interview the usually careful
leader of the Senate Mitch McConnell
Revealed the political use of the canard that Social Security can add to the deficit in a TV interview
He's tried to shift attention away from the Trump
2017 tax cuts
And moved it towards costly entitlements. That's the code for Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
He said that they were the real drivers of the death
Not the tax cuts and calls for Social Security and other entitlements to be adjusted the demographics of the future
Republicans in particular in particular have always aimed to cut Social Security out of a general
ideological opposition to government programs, but the
Idea the argument the proposition that Social Security as to the deficit is wrong. So in conclusion
Social Security can't add to the deficit because it's designed
By law to be self-contained the reason why past congresses and presidents
insisted on the actuarial based trust fund funding first for Social Security
And then for Medicare was to create a framework for a discipline Congress and it worked Social Security benefits are extremely low
Benefits can't be raised to penny without raising Social Security revenue first and if it isn't Social Security
Who and what can add to the deficit and debt? Well, they've already told us to be sure
It's the 2017 Trump tax cuts and the Senate Republicans and the House Republicans
They're projected to add one to two
Trillion dollars to the debt. It's about 164 billion unto the deficit
Large deficits and debt will result from these sugar-daddy of tax cuts in 2017
It's bad policy in flush times in good economic times like we have now
To not cushion for the bad times that's bad policy. But Social Security
cushioned for the bad times which are now
people living long and also many people retiring so
Congress can add to the deficit and debt through every other program and tax provision in the federal budget
but not through Social Security Social Security is off limits every penny paid now and in the future
must be paid for
Every penny paid out and every penny promised must be paid for with money coming in now and in the future
Perhaps we should have another debate do deficits really matter, but tonight our debate
As far as I'm concerned as far as you might be concerned
And I hope you are concerned that you'll vote for me for the affirmative is
Settled Social Security can't possibly add to the deficit
Thank you very much
Teresa Aguilar Gillard, uchi and now taking the negative proposition. Mr. Jean Epstein
No, thanks. Let me begin by quoting Sir Thomas More
Who said back in the sixteenth century?
If the earth is flat could Parliament make it round if it be round?
Could the king's command?
Flatten it. Well applying that rhetorical question to the 21st century
The earth is round and nothing our government can do or say can flatten it
Similarly, even though the government might continue to declare that. It's in possession of a nearly three trillion dollar trust fund
Nothing it can do or say can summon that trust fund into being
That's because the trust fund doesn't exist
And since there is no trust fund the resolution fails
there is no trust fund to cover the cost of social security any more than there was a trust fund to cover the cost of
spending on the government's Wars
since the dollars spent on the wars can add to the federal deficit so to
Condole are spent on payouts from the Social Security system
On the surface at least you might think that those in the know are on Theresa's side
consider the coverage of Social Security's finances in the Wall Street Journal which has a reputation for
Grasping fiscal realities an April 22nd story in the journal begins by referring to the trust fund
Though as though it does exist the lead sentence reads quote
Social Security's costs are expected to exceed its income in
Forcing the government to dip into its nearly three trillion dollar trust fund to cover benefits unquote
based on that statement
It sounds as though Teresa must be right as long as the program is able to keep dipping into its fund of nearly three children
To cover benefits it is indeed
Self-funded and it can't be adding to a federal deficit
But as a sign of the doublethink
That plagues so many accounts of this topic the same article goes on to assert that Social Security
Has in fact been contributing to the deficit we read quote that
Rising Social Security costs have contributed to larger deficits that are set to exceed one trillion a year
starting in 2020 unquote
notice from the wording of that statement that Social Security will not only contribute to the deficit in
2020 it is already been doing so
the same kind of inconsistency
plagues the nonpartisan Congressional Budget Office
Which puts out reports that warn of rising deficits and the cost of Social Security as a major
Contributor and yet it too uses the term trust fund as though the trust fund actually exists
the reason for the glaring inconsistency
is fairly simple
these establishment sources feel obligated to acknowledge that there is a trust fund if the government claims there is
In
but but the pretense is dropped once they turn their attention to the real life issue of
soaring federal deficits in
Similar fashion had the king in Thomas More's time actually declared that the world is flat
Established sources would no doubt have given due acknowledgment to the Kings viewpoint
but when it came to the serious matter of
Navigating the globe in the high seas, the pretense would also have been dropped in
2013 the fact that the trust fund doesn't exist got exposed for all the world to see
Except that few noticed it that was when the Republican Congress was refusing to raise the debt limit
Which meant that the government was facing difficulty paying its bills
President Obama released a warning that if the debt limit wasn't raised
Social Security checks might not be sent out
the warning exposed an obvious fraud
Wasn't there supposed to be a Social Security trust fund? And if so
How could there be any concern about sending out the Social Security checks a trust fund if it exists
consists of assets like stocks and bonds
So if the need arose why not just sell off some of the assets and cover the payouts in the in that way
Yet the media to Obama's warning seriously
without
Realizing that he was as good as admitting that there is no trust fund
To better grasp why there is no trust fund it helps to understand how such a fund could have been created in
the early 1980s the baby boomers were screaming into the labor markets and
retirees were collecting Social Security checks
and they were not so numerous the payroll tax that is earmarked for Social Security checks, which had
container ating surpluses
the surpluses could have been invested in the stocks and bonds of other advanced economies including
Bonds issued but creditworthy foreign governments as well as in the domestic US market in the same way other countries
maintain sovereign wealth funds for example
The government of Norway has a fund valued at more than 1 trillion with a portion of the assets currently invested in
high-tech stocks in the US
Had these investments been made as the surpluses came in
They would indeed have been a trust fund with real assets
And these those assets could gradually be sold off to fund social security
This would have meant that payouts to beneficiaries would not have boosted federal deficits
The system would have been self-funded just as Teresa claims it is
But that's exactly what did not happen
Instead the surpluses from Social Security were used each year to cover other
expenses of the federal government all the money got spent and then some
leaving no money to invest in assets to create a trust fund and
At the same time an accounting fraud had been engineered as the surpluses were generated
Bonds were created technically referred to as general accounting series or GIS securities
Matching the surpluses in the same dollar amounts the GA s securities have been put into the account of the Social Security
trustees the debt is also known as
Intragovernmental debt, which is debt the government owes to itself
So when the Wall Street Journal refers to the Social Security system
Dipping into the trust fund to cover benefits. It is really talking about an exercise that will only keep
bureaucrats busy
Here's how that exercise works to meet its obligations the Social Security
Administration submits the GS s securities for payment to the US Treasury
Say the amount is 50 billion. These bonds are liabilities to the Treasury
Just like all Treasury bonds are that
50 billion will be an outlay of the Treasury in the same way that the Treasury makes any other outlay the
Treasury will cut a check to the Social Security Administration
For 50 billion and then Social Security will use this 50 billion to cover its obligations to its beneficiaries
but obviously the transfer of 50 billion from the Treasury to Social Security is no different in result from a 50 billion transfer from the
Treasury to the Pentagon or to the agricultural department or to any other agency of government?
That needs to pay its bills and there is no trust fund for the Pentagon or AG
Department since the fiscal result for Social Security payouts is
Exactly the same the trust fund is an accounting fiction
by analogy
Imagine your parents give you what they claim to be a trust fund worth 1 million dollars
You find that instead of being a rich kid holding 1 million in stocks and bonds
You have been given 1 trillion in IOUs signed by then
When you object they explain that this is intra personal debt money. They owe themselves
Similar to the Treasury's intragovernmental debt money the government owes itself
You'll be tempted to tell them that what they call a trust fund has funds that can't quite be trusted
Of course
the difference is that your parents don't have the power to borrow like the US government does but if they two are
living beyond their means
Then payouts to you for the IOUs in the trust fund
also add to their deficit or
Imagine a private firm running its pension fund in this same way
Workers contribute to the pension fund and are told by the firm that their surplus
Contributions are being invested in assets it then comes to light that the company's actually
Spent all the surpluses while creating
IOUs against the firm's own revenue, the firm would be criminally guilty of fraud
the US government did the same thing the main difference being that it spent the
surpluses on its foreign wars and the other difference being that the federal government's
Criminality is exempt from the law
legal points have been made about the fact that Social Security holds these GS securities while agencies like the Pentagon and the
agricultural Department
Don't the argument. Is that the existence of these securities?
Guarantees the Social Security payouts will be made while there is no such guarantee
For agencies that lack the GSS securities. So let's call these securities
legally binding memos to the file
But it makes no sense to call them a trust fund and makes an existence of the legal. Memos cannot prevent
Payouts from being cut at any time
the Congressional Budget Office
Actually takes pains to explain all that
I've just said in the sea bolts January release on the 10-year budget outlook
There is a discussion of the Social Security trust fund that pretends the trust fund exists
Well at the same time dropping the pretense quo
the trust fund is an asset for the individual program such as Social Security but a lot but a liability for the rest of the
the resources to redeem a trust-fund securities and therefore pay for benefits or other spending in some
Future year must be generated through taxes income from other governmental sources or borrowing from the public
Unquote as the SIBO points out then
redemption of the Trust Fund securities must be generated through taxes income from other governmental sources, or
Borrowing from the public and of course that applies to all spending by government
since all spending can only be generated through taxes income from other governmental sources or
Borrowing from the public the see both and nods in the legal direction
But still delicately concludes as follows quote
Trust funds have an important legal meaning in that their balances are a measure of the amounts that the government has
Legal authority to spend for certain purposes under current law
But they have little
relevance in an economic or budgetary sense
Little relevance is of course a bureaucratic euphemism for no
relevance at all
in her essay in Forbes Theresa invert
Inadvertently makes the C boson point she writes quote if you are wondering if the trust fund is real
Here are facts to judge for yourself workers do two things with their FICA taxes
We pay current benefits and we say by buying US Treasury bonds like many wealthy people do unquote
Already, it is a stretch to say that the baby boomer has made a conscious decision to buy those bonds have they actually been asked
They might have realized that it was a much better idea to invest the surpluses in
Outside assets to prevent the money from being grabbed and spent by the government but what Teresa ads next gives the game away
Quote when we threw Social Security free rights invest in government bonds the government creates
intragovernmental debt
She then provides as a source that defines intragovernmental debt a link to a source and according to that source in
Governmental debt is the portion of the federal debt
Oh to other agencies the source continues by owning Treasuries, they the agencies
Transfer their excess cash to the general fund where it is spent
Note the source says where it is spent not where it's invested in
Assets to create a trust fund
So according to Teresa's own source
And just as a Seaver points out redemption of the trust fund securities must be generated through taxes income from other governmental sources
Or borrowing from the public
According to a former CBO budget director the federal government's budget is on the road to hell
The adds quote there is no polite way to describe what the world's largest
economy has placed itself on a trajectory that looks like a third-world debt crisis the
Cost of Social Security now account for a record twenty three point seven percent of all federal outlays and are due to keep rising
Faster than either total federal outlays our gross domestic product
That's why the SIBO constantly cites it as one key reason why federal deficits are running out of control
Although it's far from the only reason Teresa and I could talk about ways to tame the deficit since we are both
Bleeding hearts were both concerned about the plight of the elderly who have planned they rounded lives around elder care
entitlements including Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
But unfortunately, we're bogged down in a myth
She would still have us believe that Social Security is playing no active role in keeping the budget on that road to hell
But that's exactly what it has been doing. Let me conclude with a quote from the HBO miniseries
Chernobyl
Every lie we tell ourselves
incurs a debt to the truth
sooner or later that debt must be paid
Thanks
Thank You Jay
Chernobyl is a is a comedy right? Chernobyl is a comedy
Make sure that okay Teresa you have five minutes to respond
You can either sit or you can stand either whatever but you can't do both
so choose wisely I
Haven't heard Sir Thomas Moore as a source for public policy since I was at Notre Dame
Sure, absolutely
So let's say in 1990
You inherited real assets you got some stock from some real companies you got
$20,000 worth of Enron stock
General Motors stock
You got of stock and some real American companies like Kmart and Montgomery Ward's
But you did not get any of those real assets called a government bond right in 19
in
2019 which were real assets the government bonds or
Stock in Enron GM the old company
Kmart in monkey Ward's just because
the asset portfolio of Social Security is in
Conservative and it's in government bonds the most valuable asset on the planet
When the when hell really happens in the financial sector where does everybody including the Norwegians?
Go they come here and buy our
bonds
So we as American have two trillion of those bonds and they will be paid
I'm reminded jr. Reminded me of
President George W Bush
who went to
In his campaign his losing campaign to privatize Social Security
Went to the to the government agency that held these bonds in there on paper. It's a show
in their lockbox another
accounting
Metaphor an illustration and said huh? Just like gene. Those aren't real assets. Haha. You're like he does
The government official is standing there looking a little bit nervous within five minutes
Secretary Treasury snow went out into the world fear and said he didn't really mean it
He really didn't mean it. But gene said what George Bush said these are real assets the world
Norwegians we really will pay them back
So what is in the trust fund is very real at all. They are contingent claim. They are claims on
Future generations just like the stock in Amazon is it is saying when I redeem this?
It's a bond. I will expect the money to come from
profits from
workers from somewhere all of
Finance is a claim a paper claim on assets
What is real is whether or not you'll be paid back and the US government is good
For its money and we're lucky to have that much money in our trust fund in
terms of the deficit
it does really matter whether or not that deficit adds the debt that will drain your
household or your nation to pay it back if we owed all of our debt to say China and
We were obligated
To pay it back
Then we would drain productivity
GDP per capita
would fall
But if we borrow from each other like the Japanese have for 20 years
their debt-to-gdp
Ratio is beyond any textbook?
Definition of what is sustainable its sustainable because they borrow their debt is all internal
Just as you borrow from your spouse, perhaps you borrowed
$20,000 from your spouse your household debt and deficit did not change if you borrowed from the Mafia
You would have a very different
Position and you might be on the road to hell is where I'm going to close now
with
the definition of real health and
That would be if the 2035
We cut Social Security benefits which half of our population
Depend on in their old age to stay in their house
There'll be more people on the street along with Earl on David's Street. Um
Living that way and that's true hell not an accounting entry
About the deficit. Thank you
Thank You Teresa I
Do want to point out as somebody who was once married and lent money to my wife
Or rather I borrowed money from her. It was a lot like being
borrowing money from the Mafia but
Jane you have five minutes
Got a moderator really editorialized as a lad. I don't usually go but I mean don't count all moderation is on a biography chain. I
First of all, I don't
I I completely agree with Theresa that it would have been a bad idea to invest in in Enron
Obviously as Teresa knows you've got a very good book about retirement planning if you've bought, you know, the sp500
You would have done very well since 1990. If you'd bought the world stock index. You would have done very well
The Norwegians are actually invested in our high-tech stocks at the moment
But all that's all really by the way the the point that that Teresa herself
Acknowledges is that this debt is?
intra
Governmental debt, and she herself provides a link to a source that explains
Intra governmental debt what the government owes itself and the source I didn't quote from the source completely
The source continues the cruellest that she herself links to to explain this intragovernmental debt by owning Treasuries
they the agencies transfer their excess cash to the general fund where it is spent I
Read that already it was spent now
I assume that Teresa would have preferred a world in which the the Social Security
so security actually would have been a locked box to use the term of Clinton and gore and
And if they wanted they were aiming to balance the budget
They would have bounced the budget but instead they raided the funds and they blew the money. I
Would basically argue on their Foreign Wars because you could choose something else
They would have spent it on, you know
because obviously they just spent it but the Foreign Wars came up and they blew it and Cheney said
You know deficits don't matter. So that's what happened. That's where they blew it. That's theories
Well, so what did so then they created this intragovernmental debt?
and and the source that Teresa herself
Cites writes, of course one day they will redeem their Treasury notes for cash
That is the people holding the interest
The Social Security system will redeem that and the federal government will either need to raise
Taxes or issue more debt to give the agencies the money they will need again
That's the way the federal government spends money on everything
they give that when the debt comes and they pay it that's
Intragovernmental debt what the government owes to itself and what the government owes to itself is again what you might owe to yourself?
It's not an asset and and that's why
Whenever anybody gets real as in the case of The Wall Street Journal or the Congressional Budget Office
They they blame the Social Security system
For the rising debt, because the Social Security system is rising so quickly. I share I share
Teresa's concern about the future I share it and then some and you know
It's not gonna be it's not gonna kill people like Chernobyl but it is the road to hell and in fact in fact
She's concerned about
2035 well, I suggest Teresa that you read the Congressional Budget Office projections for the next ten years
But on the basis of plausible
assumptions they show that it's possible that the cost of just
servicing the debt
Will will exceed a trillion dollars by 2028
But and that will be a 15 percent of the federal budget that the Vera budget will be spending more on
Servicing the debt than it does on
so-called defense
So that's when they may start pulling the plug that that's psychological threshold of a truly in doubt right now
It's about a little under 400 billion a year to service the debt, but the on the basis of conservative assumptions
It could go up to trillion by
2028 and that's at a point where they could start cutting the benefits in the way that they usually do boost the inflation measure
boost the age
Tax more they could reduce benefits in lots of ways
So I'm concerned just as Teresa is my contention
Ironically is that by denying that the Social Security system is contribute to the deficit and by the way
Medicaid all the other elder care programs are actually contributing even more. It's really the entire elder care package
That is at risk
There is a danger the federal government may pull the plug on a lot of old people
You can end welfare as we know it potentially for 30 year olds
You can't end l took your elder care as we know it for 75 year olds
but that I fear is the direction in which we're going and that's partly because unfortunately,
regrettably tragically people like Teresa choose to ignore
the fact that
Social Security is indeed a major problem in terms of the federal debt all the deficit
Although by the way, I hasten to add that Medicaid and Medicare are even more problematic. Thanks
Thank you very much, Jeanne, okay
Yeah
We are going to the audience question and answer period so please line up on the side of the lobby
I'm going to take the moderators prerogative and ask two quick questions one of each Jean. Are you on Social Security? Yes
Yeah, and so you are part of the problem you're adding to our deficit by your own logic
Well, I actually
was
Donating while I was working. I was donating my Social Security check to people like you Nick
So it's like exacta bases lights they only socially check Oliver
Thanks, like reason but ever since I got fired from my job, and I don't know anything from that from the soul forum
I figured I'm devoting a lot of time and energy to furthering what's gone
But indeed I'm probably like one of those guys who's flying around warning people about global warming. Well leaving could be the moral
Good the fact that I'm a hypocrite
Should not necessarily invalidate my argument. There we go. And then
for Teresa
I guess and I just want to make sure of this is your position that intragovernmental debt is not real debt
Use your microphone
my position is that Social Security is
Self-contained unlike the military budget or unlike Medicaid although you agree
I mean that the money that has been raised and that was put in surplus has already been spent so
The government is going to have to come up with that to replace that somewhere. That's right. Okay, okay
let's go to the audience first question, please and I will be
Epstein Ian in
Ask a question. Don't make a statement. Okay?
Thank you, I
Don't
Quite understand the question. So if Nick can you help me out?
Jane did you want to quickly reprise your
your trust fund analogy instead of investing in
stocks and bonds
I will stipulate for you to be said instead of investigating in an index fund which does generally
yield returns over 10 20 year period
They've created IO use to themselves
Interpersonal intrapersonal debt. Okay. I got it
so you would have preferred that we
That we take from the future
That the parents would have taken from the their children
By by investing in those in the stock market and then redeeming it
but that also
means that you would have to resell those those stocks and bonds and
The either the corporation would have to pay out of someplace. So it really is
Immaterial to me and to the structure of Social Security whether or not in 1985 we started to invest in bonds
Government bonds or we started to invest in this market completely immaterial. It was a political question why they didn't
Okay next question
As much as I abhor a social security and what it does to me
Alas as much as Jean and I used to be friends I
Have to acknowledge that Teresa is 100% correct?
Resolution
Do you?
have a question or are you going to also go a
Band for all seasons there might be a soliloquy that you want to pull out. Oh, no. No, please
What is the question was simply one statement?
So I'd like you to Teresa to
Address two issues one is the Bugaboo of the intragovernmental debt
The
Social Security trust fund it's not per se without government
it could be considered something like China or any other debtor and
Also
the
statement by
Obama which was brought up about not being able to pay and what he really meant
Is that America would renege on its debts?
Thank you, really? See I'll take the Obama first even Obama can make a mistake. And in fact when we had when we
He was just you really read this audience wrong
Even Saint Obama can make a mistake and it was proven to be mistaken because when we went through sequestration and they cut
Every agency because of the way Social Security is set up there were no there were no cuts
But that means the way Social Security is set up that when it doesn't have enough revenue coming in
Benefits will be cut and that's not true of any other other agency except for the Highway Trust Fund and part of the Medicare
Did you want to address the second point and which was?
It was mental Janice yes, yes the intergovernmental debt. I feel like we're in public finance class
the fact that one agency
owes another agency the Treasury owes
the US government I mean the u.s. Of Social Security
Really was a device to keep Social Security benefits in check, right?
That's the whole trust fund set up was a political framework
To keep Social Security benefits in tech if we want to raise Social Security benefits
Just like if we have to like go to Congress and fight for it if we want em
so
But the economic effect what let's say we're all economists now is very very different
then if you borrow from your spouse or from the Mafia if it's if it's internal national debt between
Each other or if it is an external debt and that has a very different economic effect. So that's that's good
And Thompson
You're not my friend or I still love you and and I want you to know that we've been getting personal is evening
I mean, obviously
Obama knew what he was talking about?
he knew of course that
The you know, the media wouldn't care. And of course Social Security is the third rail of American politics and that's of course why?
Away, the payments were made. Clearly there would have been a massive rebellion
And of course, basically that was good thing you don't as I keep saying you don't pull the plug on 75 year olds
And so that was good
and of course
They had the political clout to make sure the social security pants were made not because of these bogus assets
That that they held and I guess there's you do
You agree that intragovernmental debt is a has a different economic effect than public debt. Well,
in Chicago coming on no that is an accounting fraud in two inter-government metal debt is
Exactly the same as my saying that I have intrapersonal debt. I owe a trillion dollars to myself
That's an accounting fraud. There's no such thing as as assets of debt. It's it's a complete wash
Unlike what you seem to have said ed. I forgot to correct you on that
Look Social Security system is obviously part of the federal government
and so we if we wiped away the intragovernmental debt Social Security isn't the only agency the hell's that the
Operations of the budget would be exactly the same. The only difference would be this legal argument that because
You know a legal argument that bad if I give my io u--'s to my son that
That that's kind of a moral claim, but that's that's just a debt
I owed to myself and that's clearly clearly a wash
That's clearly which which knee would you break gene?
When you collect on your own debt, would you go right right like a left leg?
There are certain questions Nick puts you which I which can't be north dad. They should not even be entertained. Next question please sir
Well, if the last question Aaron gene love each other. I'm Theresa's husband
There is so much love there is so much love that dare speak its name in this room tonight at so Paul's
A great lady. Absolutely, so
The issue of how the federal government pays
The debts that it knows whether that's to China or to Norway or to the Social Security trust fund
so far we've only focused on
Cutting benefits for Social Security. Why not raise
revenues the deficit in 2018
84% of it can be attributed to the trope and Bush tax cuts or is that outside?
I know if that's outside
The scope is the maybe we seem to be focusing only on solving the social security
Repayment for the money that it's given to the federal government by doing something within that system
There's lots of ways the federal government could pay back well
That's first of all, that's a very fair question
And as I said if we can give up on the myth that Social Security is not adding to the deficit
of course it is and when you talk about
Paying China Peng. Whoever all I keep emphasizing. Is that is that
Astok SIBO itself says there's no budgetary reality to the trust fund
When the Treasury pays Social Security it's exactly the same transfer as when the Treasury pays the AG department
Or the Pentagon or any other agency of government. It's exactly the same operation
That's why the trust fund is an accounting fiction, but getting to your question
Absolutely, we could discuss this if we could talk about revenues and expenses as the Congressional Budget Office
Puts out a whole series of programs and plans for taming the soaring deficit the budget is on the road to hell
I will briefly say to you that that the tax cuts imposed
by the government clearly exhausted
The deficit but had the tax cuts not been made the deficit and the debt
Would still be a very serious problem. It just would have cost phone for a few years
There's much there's many more painful things that we have to do to tame the debt
One of those things is probably to rethink the whole concept of a government handout
That also goes to the rich the the only the government can think of a charity plan to help the rich
Private-sector charities just want to target it to those who need the government wants to give it to everybody. That's dumb
Thank you next question
So I was worried there for a second because
Husband almost asked my questions, but I didn't quite hear it again, sir. So, let me see if I can try
Welcome welcome. Thanks Jane. All right, so because as I was listening to this
I got very excited because it seems to me that Jean Epstein is in effect
Advocating a tax hike and so this is something we can get together on
because if Social Security is adding to the deficit as you argued and
if it would be a disaster if it wasn't paid out as you argued, and if
Just about anything else we could do to square that circle would be far more controversial than this which also seems true
Then shouldn't we be lifting the cap so that the the rich are paying their fair share in Social Security?
How about have an ending? Our foreign war has been I
Mean I'm for it, but that's good, man
Ben is a friend
I he's a socialist I debated on the Dave Smith a part of the problems show just a week ago the entire soulmates
So let's end those foreign wars first Ben, don't you think good idea?
I love I don't know if it's realistic that we're gonna end up first. Okay. Well, you're a radical socialist Ben
do you want to so so I think
You and I are in the same page about radicalism, let let's let's deal with the real problems other government because I
If we if we hike taxes, we're only going to feed those militaristic bastards more of the bullets that they want
So I think it'd be very unfortunate been you and I agree like that. Do you have any comment for okay next question
Thank You
Mrs. Geller guchi I'm trying to understand your argument. So I think I'm going to ask a couple of
Maybe one and a half question, maybe one of those so first of all to understand your legal argument
Are you not saying because this is set up by law
Therefore it essentially should be off-mike
so the fact when they were accruing
surpluses that they should not have
counted that as a reduction in the federal deficit and now when they're paying out more than they take in they should not be
But in fact they did account it as a lesser deficit and now they are accounting it as a bigger deficit, isn't that right
And then I want to get to 2035
Because you're saying in 2035. Well the way it's set up
The benefits get reduced to whatever the income is in any given year. Yeah, but then you say but we'll never let that happen
So, of course the benefits are going to be up but if that's true
Isn't there gonna be a deficit then and if we all acknowledge, but that's gonna happen
The benefits are being a crude right now. Shouldn't that be accounted as part of the debt? No, that's a great
That's a really good clarification and I did try to say that in my opening statement
You know, I I really think I do win the debate because
Jeanne did swerve to talk about the problems with the debt and the deficit. I really want to focus on the proposition that the
Social Security is treated by
By the people who?
collect revenue and spend money as off budget and proof of that is
because it is off its treated as off budget in a trust fund like a couple of other agencies do it can only
pay it can only spend
What it takes in?
It does mean that in 2035
I used to think five years ago that will never happen the results the consequences of cutting benefits
there are just too tragic, but the closer we get to 2035 and nothing has been done to raise taxes or to
Bring in more revenues. I think it might happen
It could very well happen because it will effect actually on the bottom half the distribution much more than the rich so it is not
Axiomatic like the CBO is required to account for that
The promised benefits now will be paid only scheduled benefits
there are promise for scheduled benefits only benefits that can be paid will be paid it is true that
Politically now we're having this debate about adding to the deficit because it's redeeming as treasury bonds before when Social Security
masked the deficit that Congress really was running it was never put on the the
Budget because of the surplus made it look like government was being responsible
So we maintain
We keep it off budget
Treat it that way and then Jeanne and I and Ben and everybody else
Can then debate what government should spend and what it should tax and who should pay for it?
Well, well I wanted to come and thanks for the question
Buddy, Menten and yeah, yeah, and I just want to comment that indeed what happened was in
the Clinton administration declared that the budget was balanced and
The only reason they were able to do that
is that they were counting the surpluses from Social Security and so
Here ironically I to reason I completely agree
Starting in 1980 or thereabouts when the but when the death when the but when the surplus has started to be created
They should not have been counted and then obviously the Social Security system could have invested the money
But indeed what happened was the government
Raided the surpluses and spent the money and so that was indeed. What?
Had it happened in the private sector. It would have been regarded as criminal fraud and so
Just as you suggest then had that happened then then then a balanced budget had to be achieved then without
Including this pension fund and the pension fund could have done but the government by the way
Runs the federal government runs pension funds but of course
and of course state governments often raid their pension funds so
Raiding a pension fund is a very standard practice on the part of the federal government and that's what happened
And so since we're doing that, right, that's why it's adding to the deficit. Okay next question
Kind of piggybacking off that last question, it seems like you both agree that the accounting is a fiction
Externally like it's off budget externally. So I guess my question is like does this question even matter?
You know K. Wow, I mean I heard the household
like the household analogy if the house has a net worth of a hundred thousand the parents lend twenty thousand of the kid who goes
And spends it
They now have a net worth of eighty thousand
Now the parents have an IOU of twenty thousand to the kids
But that's internal like the net worth of the house
Is still 80 thousand on the other side if they have a hundred thousand dollars and they lend money outside
So they actually owe external debt twenty their net worth is still
80,000. So from the external perspective the account the internal accounting is a fiction and if you both agree on that
Why does this question matter? Okay who wants to jump at that?
You know you say that fiction you talk like fiction like is a bad thing
It is it is a design
it is designed purposely as a trust-fund to discipline it I said that in my opening remark, so it was
contrived that it wasn't an open-ended entitlement that every single promise had to be
Had to be paid for it was the original pay for
The economic effect of that household analogy on the household is very very different if you owe it externally
Or if you owe it in between each other
but that is off the the point and if we're going to be Oxford style we have to
Stick to the to the resolution can Social Security add to the deficit? Not at all?
It can look like it depending upon what?
Congress or the CBO does at that moment either included in the unified budget or off budget?
But the behavior of Social Security is that it can never add to the deficit
No, why does it matter a young man? And the reason why it matters is that I'm sorry soon clear that it's condescending
but but all of my young white hunk
He's wearing as baseball hat back where it's genies laughing
I think that what toward it. Oh, there were Theresa and I have done it part of the problem
Is that if you use about nine different analogies to explain something and people's heads get a little dizzy
Look all that's really happening. Is that is that the federal budget is out of control? It's on the road to hell. It's the
Core the course of servicing the debt
Could rise to a trillion dollars
And so and so that will mean that it's going broke that will mean that as one wag said if the u.s
Goes to war with China it will have to finance war with money
It borrows from the Chinese and and and so so that's the reason why it matters the reason why it matters is that there won't
Be any goddamn elder care for you when you get old because the government is going broke. That's all that's the reality
It's not like, you know, we're not like you Jean we're never gonna grow up
So now we've got the signs coming up next question, please
And so I guess you kind of got the same kind of theme that I did
But I wanted to make it a little more simple
Maybe come from a different angle because it seemed to me that
A lot of what you guys are speaking is just very very technical and I don't think that's necessary
Yeah
my question for you, is this if you both agree that
In order to fulfill the benefits Center promise today
We need more money whether it's by raising the payroll tax to make everybody whole
Or if it is by breaking the law that we have before and simply raising taxes to do it
Which I suppose would be your case of a breeze the deficit think what real difference is there
Isn't that kind of like are you gonna pay from your left pocket or your right? I think it's just too much technicalities here
I mean they can onyx and that you're gonna pay war no matter what okay
Can I ask you a question I
What if we raised your taxes, but what if we tripled the taxes we posed on you tripled the taxes we imposed on you
I'm sorry
You would not be happy well the Congressional Budget Office has basically said that
in effect
That in order in order to balance the budget in order to avoid the fiscal time bomb in order to prevent the government from being
On the road to hell it will in effect have to triple the taxes that you pay
So I assume that if you accept my word that that's true, then you are concerned not
Say I'm not well
You triple your but your taxes I
Think he's arguing that the debate is actually then how do we you know, how should the program be shrunk or something?
but Teresa
That's that's one solution tripling your taxes
Yeah, I mean I I do want to win so I keep on going to the technical aspect, you know of the proposition
But you know, we're all really on the same page
Cutting social the way Social Security is set up is that if we don't make an affirmative?
Step to raise more revenue by raising the payroll tax or expanding the base lifting the cap then we are going to cut benefits
Because Social Security is structured not to address and I would just throw in and no it's just moderator getting to
spout off here
I mean it's a program that was started in
1935 and then was kind of renewed under Ronald Reagan who talked about how the greatest achievement of his presidency was to
You know that you have reformed and put on
financial footing firm financial footing for another generation this horrible New Deal program that he was arguing against in the early sixties that
You know, maybe it's time that we rethink the whole idea or what kind of social safety net. We need for older people
Who are now extremely wealthy but that's a kind of separate issue. Let's go to the next question
So I'm a fan of a number of your arguments here Jean
But I do have one specific question for you a few times you've mentioned this 20 trillion dollar debt and the eventual trillion dollar
Per year payment to service the debt, but you're also arguing that
Intergovernmental debt is an accounting fraud
So at least according to the Treasury is this current analysis that would peg our debt at right around 16 trillion
Well, well, absolutely. I did not good question
I did not wanted to get us into the swamp, but I never used that 20 trillion dollar figure
They the debt the debt owed to the public. It's the only debt that the cost of servicing
The debt is only the debt owed to the public and you're quite correct at 16 trillion and and the CBO's projections
are all
Adherent to the debt owed to the public including over trillion dollars over to the Chinese. So you're absolutely right
But in fact that trillion-dollar debt servicing is strictly debt owed to the public the intragovernmental debt
Which adds to that again is complete fiction
Okay. Thank you next question
Thank you, this can be for either party by the way, we're only talking about 2.8 trillion, I believe I
routinely I own some bond funds and I routinely
During the year sell some bond funds to do
Rebalancing of a portfolio. I will purchase some stock funds from time to time and vice versa my question concerning this
Trust fund would it be possible do the dollars literally exist?
Could those 2.8 trillion dollars be used?
today to purchase 2.8 trillion dollars of stock assets
Thank you, Jumana
absolutely could I was just on a bipartisan Commission to examine whether or not we should do it it turns out that since we oh
We're going to were drawing down that debt that investing now in stocks. Would it be worth the risk?
It would have been worth it maybe 15 years ago
We might have gotten a higher risk of rated risk adjusted rate of return. But since we need the liquidity, it's not worth it. Well
Let me address you very good question, I think
Teresa would agree
Indeed if she's consistent with the source that she linked to that if that were done
it would mean that the budget the Treasury would have to
expend to point a trillion dollars extra
that's what it would have to do on top of the trillions are already spent because all of those
Intragovernmental debts have to be handed to the Treasury
So the Treasury simply does not have 2.8 trillion dollars to spare but it would have to do is borrow 2.8 trillion
That's what would have to happen. And so that's why the proposal is a joke. I would also just add
the other thing that would be terrifying is the idea if I I think if the government goes into the stock market then you
Politicize you essentially socialize the entire economy. Yeah, they show
Final question, there's no more questions. There are no more questions
The questions have all been asked never happened to be the toasts have all been made. The wine has all been drank
we are going to now open the voting again to
You know what I forgot I skipped ahead I missed the best part we've got five minutes each of final
Post Buttle I guess right and gene. Do you go first in this or does Theresa?
Okay, because you're negative. So you have five minutes. You can sit you can stand you can dance
At least that's what I hear you can but whichever okay, so five minutes
And bring it on home. Alright
Well, I win the debate
Because what gene did was worth off the debate with a very worthy
argument about how much what the government should be spending if it's worthy does it bring
Actually doesn't make our nation richer and to invest in Foreign Wars
And to cut taxes for the rich doesn't make us healthier
Smarter more able to face the future or more productive. So that's a worthy debate, but it just isn't this one
This one is about whether or not Social Security system is structured
to cause
the the us the us nation to add to
The debt the further debt that we're going to have to raise taxes and pay back later by law
It is structured so that it can't pay more
Than it brings in now right now
It is drawing from the general Treasury
just like many of you who are redeemed your pension funds and retirement accounts are drawing from the
Treasury if it's all internal the economic effect is not the same as
A deficit that adds two to the dead and that's what I thought we were talking about today of
all the
Programs in the federal government and all the decision that Congress and the president makes about spending
Social Security is the absolute least of it now we can all come back another day to argue about whether or not we should raise
taxes to pay for things that we care about and I'd be happy to come back to talk about
Raising Social Security taxes to pay for Social Security because that makes our nation richer if we don't have people living on the street
Etc or children have to pay for their indebted
parents directly
All right, so I
want to
to close
to say that the Social Security system the way it's
Organized you might call it a fraud or a fiction
It just happens to be the law and the structure of our public finance the way how it is organized has actually helped
Congress keep the deficit down
It's treated as off budget. It doesn't won't apply. It's not sneaky
There is it's a very disciplined program
libertarians and conservatives
Who are true to the conservative ideology?
Would like most of the government to be funded like Social Security
To Epistle anticipate anticipated liabilities and make the political case to pay for them
so Social Security
Does not add to the deficit it certainly does not add to the debt and it doesn't have the economic
consequences of a rising
deficit and debt would have
Thank you very much. Jean your final segment
Well, we did and I did at times and along with Teresa mentioned other
ramifications of the problems that the budget faces but indeed the
Resolution is all about whether the Social Security system
adds to the federal deficit
Teresa has indicated has implied. There's only right-wingers who think so well the nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office has been
It's actually Keynesian and oriented. It's been
Run under President Obama. It was run under President Clinton. It has in
statement after statement
Highlighted Social Security as a major
Contributor to the federal deficit. Why does the nonpartisan organization?
Deeply respected by all sides keep saying that it adds to the federal deficit
well, it does so because it has
Responsibilities to do the accounting of the federal government and it has to report the truth
Social Security and now accounts for record twenty-three point seven percent of all federal
Outlays and it's due to keep rising faster than either total federal outlays a gross domestic product
It's really the elder care costs that are soaring
And the reason why SIBO constantly cites bees as one as a key reason why federal deficits are running out of control
Is that those are the parts the mandatory parts of the federal budget that keep rising I?
Wanted to emphasize that by talking about this it does not mean that I lack compassion
for the elderly who receiving Social Security
Nick himself
Outed me as a Social Security recipient, so I may be a hypocrite
but I obviously care about these elder care entitlements and
the if if we got serious about those
Problems, then we would have the compassion to recognize that the federal government the federal budget being on the road to hell
probably means that if Trump Obama Bush the 20 candidates last by last count for the
Democratic nomination Elizabeth Warren they talk about
spending more
Raising taxes but spending probably more than they could have a tax and they have the total head in the sand about
the fact that these endocrine
Entitlements are running out of control and that and that
Social Security is causing is a key cause of the federal deficits that are unsustainable
and what will happen what will happen unless
Articulate and thoughtful people like Teresa join us
What will happen is probably the crunch will hit and the federal government will start pulling the plug and it will start
Ending welfare as we know it for 75 year olds for 80 year olds
that's the kind of lack of compassion a federal the government is capable of the same government that
raided that pension fund for so many years and
And and did not allow those funds to be invested
So again, I would only ask you to consider if indeed the trillion dollar trust fund
Is preventing Social Security from adding to the federal deficit then?
Why does the non partisan partisan Congressional Budget Office? Why has the non personal?
partisan Congressional Budget Office been talking about the Social Security as a
Contributor as a main contributor to the deficit every time you open
one of its reports I
Submit that the resolution fails and that you should vote no on the resolution
It does indeed add to the federal deficits. The rest is all accounting nonsense
A matter of law is what Teresa says
I will land on my quote from Thomas More paraphrasing them a little bit if the King passed a law
That the world is flat
Would that make itself? Thank you very much. Thank you very much
Now, let's have a big hand a big round of applause for Teresa. Killaura Tucci and Jean Epstein
For debating this we're going to open the vote in now
So, please go back to Soho vote calm and we'll have a couple of minutes
I'll try and do some patter. You know, let's you know, I had a really nice
Really nice lunch today that I could talk about but instead one of the things I'll
Talk about our upcoming
debates for the sohe forum on Monday, July 15th
Renegade university had Thaddeus Russell
He's a Columbia trained historian will defend the resolution post-modernism is
Necessary for a politics of individual liberty against Rockford University professor Stephen Hicks author of explaining post-modernism
Hicks is an arch critic
sad Russell is a
Proponent of post-modernism that should be great Monday August 12th, George Celgene director of the Center for monetary and financial alternatives
Will defend the resolution bitcoin is poorly suited to the purpose of becoming any nation's main medium of exchange
against Safa Dean a moose author of the Bitcoin standard the decentralized alternative to central banking that one is
Real hot ticket if you want to look for that it's if it's not already sold out
Tuesday on September 10th part of the problem podcast host Dave Smith
Our warm-up back tonight. We're still all kind of toasty from his comedy
will defend the resolution the
Libertarian party should never again put up national candidates whose views are similar to those of gary johnson and bill weld
Against nicholas or wok who SAR work? Who is the chair of the libertarian National Committee?
And then and I'll in Monday October
7th Jacob solemn he's a reason magazine senior editor and the author of saying yes in defense of drug use will defend the resolution
Except for laws prohibiting the sale of drugs to minors and driving while impaired all laws that penalize drug production distribution
Possession and use should be abolished
Along with special sin taxes on drugs and he's going up against the former New York Times reporter Alex
Berenson author of tell your children the truth about marijuana mental illness Milnes illness and violence
How many much longer do we have to two minutes, okay
Well, you know, I'm gonna go so let me recap July 15
Yeah, I know but Jean is telling people what's happening on Sunday December 8th, it just seems like kind of a stretch
All right. Well, you know go to the SOPA forum calm
Is that soma formed org dot org the Soho forum dot org?
And you can buy a VIP package where you get a bunch of different tickets. Now you get a preferential rate
You'll know you'll get in. You know that I'd say the odds are strong that both the the
post-modernism and
Okay, but renegade University, I had the postmodern debate the Bitcoin debate
these are gonna sell out go get a VIP package and that way you'll make sure you're in a
Tuesday, November 5th
Richard Wolffe University of mass professor of economics emeritus
Will defend the resolution socialism is preferable to capitalism as an economic system that promotes freedom equality and prosperity
against soho forum director Jean Epstein
Guest moderator to be announced but this is the Amherst
Maybe maybe I don't know, you know. You court me a little bit Jean, you know, it's like it's our first date for God's sake
The University of Massachusetts Amherst is one of two
Marxist economics
Departments, right the other being at Notre Dame. Oh, yeah, so this
exciting
Okay
And then Sunday December 8th
Loyola University professor of economics Walter block
Will defend the resolution while a pregnant woman should be legally required to help the fetus survive outside her body whenever that is
possible she
Retains the legal right to evict the fetus at any time during her pregnancy
And he'll be going up against Carrie Baldwin of the MIR Liberty podcast
so the fetal, you know, that's the perfect Christmas season a
Producer Scrooge will be the guest moderator gene the essence of where you where you come up with resolutions like that
I don't know and he picked the fetus, you know
Yeah, and then the last sketch of the scheduled debates is Monday January 6 best-selling author in Silicon Valley
Entrepreneur Martin Ford will defend the resolution
Robotics will soon lead to widespread joblessness underemployment and the concentration of wealth in the hands of a few
against Anthony Sam Roffe co-host of the Scottish liberty podcast and author of
universal basic income for and against
All right
Do fetuses get the universal basic income or then they could pay rent right? They wouldn't have to be evicted
Yeah now that's true yeah, they've got rent control but nobody gets evicted okay we are let me move over
Here is the
Finding okay now remember
Given Social Security's nearly three trillion dollar trust fund the system cannot add to the federal deficit Theresa
Was saying yes to that the pre vote
Was eight point three percent said, yes, they agreed with the proposition
Forty four point seven nine percent forty five percent said no
It cannot add to the deficit
And undecided was forty six forty seven percent
It can it can add
No, is that it cannot?
okay, so the post is
For the yeses went from eight point three percent to fifteen percent for a change in about six point two five percent
So that's in an Teresa's favor
The nose went from forty five percent to eighty percent for a change of thirty five percent
And the undecided went from forty six percent to five percent. So that means a gene is the winner
Congratulate for a very interesting
Thank you all for coming plays. The bar is still open. There are recent magazines all over the place. Hang out a lot more
Thank you for coming